bay aux trousses et squeeze aujourd'hui
c'est noël et qu'est-ce qu'on fait le
jour de noël ou cambriole une maison
voilà ces affreuses que je devais plus
tarder sur the very organisé petit f la
christmas édition édition de noël c'est
parti on a déjà fait l'édition de base
d'édition halloween il manque plus que
celle ci et on est bon bah ça me fait
très plaisir de retrouver sur ce jeu à
chaque fois c'est la même galère pour
retrouver les touches alors liste des
choses à voler un parfum un blender rôle
blender je m'en souviens il est là
regardez attention il est juste nos
outils l'âme il a mis sous l'oreiller
carrément ghetto cet homme qu'est ce
qu'il fait avec humour la maladie a déjà
il ya un truc à faire ici voilà ya plus
aucune lumière dans cet appartement
hormis ce que j'ai claire éclatant et
pourquoi ne pas simplement les cadeaux
le train et on se barre c'est vraiment
un bon plan je trouve on peut voler à
hacker voilà nous fait plus chier à
aller acheter un sapin truffaut jute
seydoux aller chez le voisin prenez son
sapin c'est mignon cette petite déco
noël bon allez on va essayer de trouver
des choses quand même
eh ben mon tour elle était ce le nom à
quoi il ressemble le mec veuves dans
l'édition spéciale noël est qu'il aura
l'air carrément cool avec avec sa grande
barbe qui nous regardera comme ça de
loin mais gardera notre fée ciel plus
tard crise passe présente à huy cachent
les cadeaux c'est vrai en oui la
bouteille de parfum mont-garin non merde
ça c'est peut-être qui va pas tarder à
arriver
le sapin bloquera la porte alors on va
essayer par la merde si fermé où ces
briques ou la clé elle ou la créa se
cache d'une salle de bikelé dans des
chiottes et à tout on est dans le des
trucs aux chiottes des jeux là l'arrière
alors à la console de jeu elle est là
c'est sûr non
mais elle est où mais c'est une blague
oh oui on a eu cette fois disparates
mais arrête mais je suis bloqué par un
pot de fleurs mon gars mais barre toi te
prends comme ça je te jette aucun
respect copule bien avec sapins il va
pas tarder à arriver je le sens on va
t-on à plus de portes et france ô
que faites-vous chez moi fils de chiens
et on sera là comme des corps aux hommes
et rien du tout y'en a que deux trucs
quoi cette chaussette nous défendra au
maire dit arrive vite chaussettes
rejoint la barricade
mais je dois à quoi ils sont faits non
on est enfermé dans ses mauvaises idées
je peux très bien en train d'ouvrir mon
a rien volé [ __ ] on apprenait que
d'autres trucs pendant qu'il était pas
là bas on met carrément mauvais là mais
j'ai le plus de pression avec le balafon
qui menaçaient de couper testicules à
chaque voyage là du coup j'ai aucune
pression quant à elle au pire il fera
quoi il faudra avec sa barbe on voit la
wii mote en vol une tondeuse
tranquillement quoi mais c'est quoi ce
cadeau de noël je t'offre une tondeuse
voilà à quoi tu as que ci l'ont admis
oui ben hatira tout le jardin à tard
elle est où la clé mais il a appellé à
cacher la claquette par le conte la clé
de son bureau pour avoir le code pour
accéder au coffre la clé est né là on a
la classe
il va pas déguisé en père noël mon gars
le petit lutin vert qu'on a vu la
dernière fois à toi voilà je suis cachée
d'air la porte comme les enfants non
c'est là peut-être oui
blaise mois bref mebarkia schefer kress
mon gars je m'en vais on se dit on
descend pas peur c'est même pas une
musique épique ce que chante sous la
halle menus à bientôt on va se parler à
bientôt on va se parler on fait le tour
il a rien vu venir mon gars et regards
gardes maire dit en train de faire demi
tour mais c'est pas grave
oui c'est bien ça parle mais les cavs
ont fait des ravages partout en suisse
applique le code
quel est le code soit 69 67 assez bon à
la gaule bas on a un max de d'argent
défi de n'apporter que la porte n'est
pas cette épreuve mais au séchage coffre
royal et messieurs dames
je pense qu'il nous a mis trois petites
claques là une quatrième essai
l'hématome et on meurt mais amer mais
merde merde non un placard fuite
on est bien la taz il revient permuté
avec la guitare hommes n'avaient rien
ici à part une petite heure vous avez vu
non mais roche pour sa part amélie ch
mais non barre toi
hopla j't'embrouille merdes merci à
quatrième claquement gainey l'hématome
[ __ ] non plus car hélas c'est le bleu
celle et l'inflammation c'est les
urgences hop la plus ferme au nez quand
on va jouer à ce petit jeu longtemps
hein tu sais arrête de me courir après
arrête toi mais ça mais c'est infernal
bordel c'est génial attention diaz deux
chaises aux eaux il est chaud il fait du
co2 vous avez vu 92 monsieur ça soit ou
dans les jambes tout dans le mollet je
cherche la console à console n'y a pas
un truc cette feuille barry cadre à la
porte la pire barricades qu'on pouvait
faire n'a jamais fait de bric est aussi
pourri de chansons déconner après cet
acte parce que ce mec tu te mets la
pression quoi c'est juste un mec gagne
un boulot vers mais il me met une
pression incroyable depuis la première
fois que j'avais une vo sur ce jeu
demande quoi console tablette blender
montre mais le blender je vois toujours
pas une [ __ ] quoi y'a rien bordel
j'espère qu'il va pas être là le qu'on
allait là le complot qui voulaient
accéder à sa chambre il était encore
traduire le gac son sapin mais regardez
le sapin tu me laisses passer non laisse
le passé contre ce savon alors on perd
jamais sa peau et la sortie c'est un
savon à la cannelle et même pas la
cannelle bartois barricades
voilà tu avais ce sapin c'est le sapin
le plus légion mais arrête mais tous
sacrés ce vraiment il est vivant alors
oui la console doit bien avoir une
console soit possible à la sous
l'oreiller rien même pas une jungle
de son enfant à ce monsieur alors où est
la mode [ __ ] mais c'est incroyable
mais c'est le monde a pu planqué du
monde quoi yann bas avec une bague c'est
pareil pour sa meute il monte un petit
peu plus petit et qui donnent pas leur
bon c'est une bague quoi aller où elle a
monté montre moi le chemin montre moi le
chemin teddy là non ce carton bois
il souhaite la table de nuit sont fous
tablettes consoles blender montre non ok
ça part en bataille d'oreillers
commençons à je savais tu avais été trop
haut non je voudrais essayer je veux
tous cas dans cette maison vous
m'entendez tout portrait d'une femme
c'est sa voix la boum taxe à ces faits
le bec à peine rodez le jeu statut
c'était juste là parfait en fait ce soit
la console de jeu était dans l'évier le
blender sous la télé voilà le truc n'y a
aucune logique là y'a rien non plus
bordel mais y'a pas mais en plus ça me
donne chaud plus à berne arrive
et merde ça sonne la cre et sous
l'oreiller chez que c'est suis sur ce
genre de personne qui a des choses ses
oreillers même pas sous la table de nuit
même pas nous reste coi la console le
captage parce que c'est le train
jusqu'au bout il est il au pied du sapin
il arrive dans sa voiture mortel
hélas il ne se doute pas encore de ce
qu'il y a chez lui mais en rentrant il
découvrit un bordel monstre est un homme
dormir nu dans son lit
la tendance comme ça didou chérie tu es
rentré tard lorsqu'il se mit à lui
courir après pour le tuer c'est parti on
va attendre un peu
what on attend un peu on va attendre un
peu vrai manger incident tu ne m'auras
jamais ah ah voilà c'était ma menace la
pouvoir elle doit être là un laps ouvert
labouheyre chicken mourir par ici bien
là non ça c'est blender de tout à
l'heure pour la cré la console de jeu il
doit être là c'est sûr et hop là voilà
bientôt le train et là hop là bientôt je
vais tout souvenez ça va être encore
plus désagréable pour lui regarde et lui
sait plus quoi faire
disparition il a tenté il a feinté non
non non mais là je passe en mode énervé
je vous le dis je vous le dis je passe
en mode très énervé et lie à labouheyre
et blender leur coup on n'a pas besoin
mais c'est le foot belge de l'ue et là
il faut voler le sapin on pourra plus
bloquée avec je suis très déçu mais bon
tu n'auras tout et on est trop kitsch et
tout comme ça où on prévoit pas faire la
fête va pas refaire la party in the usa
voilà la feuille s'imagine fille bella
en me regardant bien sûr on a tout sauf
la web radio post radio je peux passer à
côté peut-être la cuisine peut-être
qu'il aime bien cuisiner en chantant cet
homme n'y a jamais rien dans cette salle
de bain à part d'un petit billet de 100
pour acheter la crème hydratante si on a
plus oui et alors la radio non c'est un
poste de radio un poste de radio ça
touche est passé devant 100 milliards de
fois non un bâtard non non je savais toi
je pense que c'est le destin le soir de
noël il ne faut pas voler quoi que ce
soit même s'il est vrai qu'une petite
part au nord avec tout ce qu'on avait
volé une fois c'est vraiment pas bien en
tout cas cette édition de me fait
plaisir
j'adore ce bull est vraiment amusant il
ya un petit stress alors pourtant c'est
le mec est carrément pas charismatique
quoi c'est pas un grand méchant qui fait
flipper c'est un mec en polo vert
j'espère ça vous a plus c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo comme
d'habitude et je vous souhaite un joyeux
noël amusez vous bien manger bien ouvrez
bien vos cadeaux comme ça vous allez pas
les ouvriers comme ça en tout cas ce
retour très vite dans une nouvelle vidéo
j'espère vous avez passé un bon moment
en famille ou entre potes ou entre
animaux aussi peut-être des années
mourir cette vidéo on ne sait pas tout
le monde mais ça
[Musique]